kommt aufgegeben scom in die speakers
corner
dort werde ich sein am samstag um 10 uhr
mit coldmirror und dann der mäßige
auftritt zoom
sie hat ja eine unglaubliche karriere
muss man schon sagen hingelegt ist in
festen diensten bei you fm war ab und zu
mit ihrem service in der ard zu sehen
also richtig unterwegs und auf youtube
weiterhin ein riesen kanal kommt man
dabei clixoom und das heißt nicht nur
meine sondern auch eure fragen werden
beantwortet wenn ihr sie hier zum
beispiel in den kommentaren unter dem
video stellt oder als video antwort
eurovideo frage hochladen einfaches
kommentarfeld klicken und dann daneben
auf den button video antwort hochladen
ansonsten den vortex lesen und kreativ
sein und dann kann eigentlich ihr wisst
es nichts mehr schief gehen bis dann
blättern